[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to being well i'm george
campbell your host joined today by
myself it's just me flying solo
they ditched me the rest of the team
is in orlando florida at our entree
leadership summit event and uh i'll be
honest i do have a little bit of fomo
that's the fear of missing out but i'm
trying to channel some jomo today that
is the joy of missing out because i have
the privilege of hosting the ramsay show
it is my privilege and i would love to
help you take the right next step with
your money so give me a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
jim's kicking off this hour in des
moines jim welcome to the ramsay show
yes thank you
how can i help today
[Music]
jim uh george i have uh i'm 63 years old
i i can see 64 in the uh in the very
near horizon i've been practicing law
for 35 years my wife and i make a
combination of about 190 000 per year
we have a one a house that the real
estate sites tell us is valued at about
1.3 million which is i believe pretty
accurate we have a 390 thousand dollar
first due to trust on that house and a
about eighty five thousand dollar second
mortgage on that house uh we have four
hundred and ten thousand dollars in uh
non-roth iras combined between the two
of us
we have um another
440 000 in in regular investment
accounts
um both are down a little bit right now
as you might imagine but uh
that's about what they are that's what
they were last friday um
i um
have six children that i put through
catholic school from kindergarten
through
to senior year in college um 102 years
of catholic education and i paid the
tuition the whole way through wow so i
now have yeah um
102 years of education yeah they're all
six have bachelor's degrees a couple of
masters daddy paid for almost all of it
happy to do so
um it was 1.2 million from the time my
oldest daughter is now 36 years old
started at college to the point my
youngest son graduated from which was
last may
i have come up with about 600 000 in my
own money and i have about 620 000 in
parent plus loans right now that hurts
[Laughter]
and uh you know they they have been very
good about saying you want to defer do
you want to hold held off they were
covered pauses um
but i think that i think that the
party's about to come to an end there
and um i'm just wanting i i'm not
without some assets as i just described
to you i'm just wondering what you think
i should do
these these people navion and the
student loan people seem to be pretty
willing to to negotiate workout payment
plans um but it'll probably be the rest
of my life um
all right all right i think i think i
think you got my story so uh
wow well uh you've done really well i
mean you guys have a great income you've
been investing but you also took on the
burden of six kids higher education
and so
what i want to do is is show you a path
to get out of this i'm sure
it was it was from kindergarten to
through college oh my god just higher
education it was it was lower middle and
in college 102 years private catholic
school the whole way
yep every every step of the way yeah was
it worth it anyway
i'm sorry
well
i think the answer is yes but uh i'm
still six hundred thousand dollars away
probably from answering the question uh
uh fully and honestly yeah
now what's the agreement with the kids
did you just say hey kids i got this
or do they feel like they should pay
some of this back
good question um the agreement was all
my kids went to very good
and expensive schools and i told them if
they
got to get in and they worked hard and
took it seriously
that that i would pay for it and all six
of them took me up on that deal and all
six of them kept there in the bargain so
it is my hope to be able to just ride
this thing throughout myself so there's
no agreement that the kids would
pay back um
if i think i got in too much trouble i
think they probably would i mean all six
are gainfully employed now all six are
doing well but they're all they're all
starting their lives now the grandkids
are coming they're buying houses they're
starting
they're getting married things like that
okay well how about this let's walk
through the math here uh how much do you
have a non-retirement you said you had
440 in a general investing account
yeah i have i have a general investment
account primarily in mutual funds and
some individual stocks of about right
about 440 000 right now which is down
from about 500 000 a couple months ago
late 2010 how much other cash do you
have in savings checkings all that just
non-retirement funds
non-retirement about another 35 000 in
cash okay so we're talking you have
about 470 of liquid cash
correct
now at your age you can touch the
retirement accounts i i'm trying to
avoid that before we do
but you need these payments out of your
life if you ever plan on retiring are
you still working i ever planned
i am but like i said i'm i'm burning
i'm burning out on that as well so yes
i've been working 90 hour weeks for 35
years and i need to break goodness
jim well
man you you uh you're not scared of work
but you've also taken on a lot of burden
for the family
yes and i'm happy to do it i'm not
complaining i'm just trying to find the
easiest exit ramp here i guess okay well
in the in the few minutes we have
remaining here's what i want to walk
through if you sold off all the
investment funds that are non-retirement
you'd be down to
uh less than two hundred thousand
dollars of student loan debt
uh that sounded about right
and minus four or four
around in very round numbers yes i'd be
about right okay and then how quickly
making 190 000 a year could we knock out
the student loans the remaining two
hundred thousand
uh maybe
two years if you hustled yeah at least
i'd have to also have to have to eat a
lot of peanut butter sandwiches but yes
and then worst case could you downsize
and home if all the kids are gone well
that
yeah we live in a 6500 square foot home
uh
we're empty nesters now there are rooms
we don't go into for months at a time so
yes
and from that deal if you sold it you
would net almost a million dollars
about 800 and something yeah but okay
yes so to me that sounds like a better
plan so this is what i i have some peace
just listening this through if you sold
off the non-retirement funds leaving you
with about two hundred thousand you
hustle to work another two years to pay
this all down while your retirement
keeps growing and then you downsize and
house and pay cash for the next one
leaving you with no payments and a bunch
of money sitting in retirement
how's that sit with you
well i you know that 440 000 provides me
with some level of security and uh
you're not secure jim you owe 620 000 to
navient
that's no security
all right you can't bankrupt on that i
mean student loans are one of the most
difficult loans to get rid of what are
the payments on six hundred and twenty
thousand dollars of student loan debt
i'm just curious
about 4 000 a month right now okay now
walk this out with me in two years the
student loan payments are gone you now
have 400 4 000 a month back in your life
that you were paying towards navient
now invest that even for 10 years at 50
grand a year you're gonna be okay in
retirement but as long as these student
loans are chaining you down you're never
going to be able to retire
and so don't get started eyed with the
investment accounts and you're doing
some fancy math over here dude you've
got to get these payments out of your
life you took on the burden and you can
get out with this income and retire with
dignity before you're 65. if i can help
it that's my plan for you jim rooting
for you man this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsay personality host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcasts all of which you can find on
the ramsay network
open phones this hour the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five i am flying solo today because
the rest of the team is in beautiful
orlando florida at our entree leadership
summit live event dave ramsey nick saban
jocko willing jade simmons patrick
lunchiony ken coleman dr henry cloud
will gudera dr john deloney jamie kern
lima jay leno dr karen limeleaf i mean
what a lineup absolutely amazing so we
got about 2 500 3 000 business leaders
out there in room many more watching on
our live stream
hoping to grow themselves their teams
their profits all of it and it's
inspiring and i got a little bit of fomo
like i mentioned earlier but i'm happy
to be here in this seat what a privilege
and an honor titus joins us up next in
atlanta georgia titus welcome to the
show
hey how are you good how are you
i'm better than i deserve boom there we
go what's up man how can i help
um so i am 13 and because i'm 13 i don't
have like a house or or any debt to pay
off
i was wondering what baby step i should
be on oh i love this question titus how
did you find out about this show at 13
years old
my parents are pretty involved they're
working their way towards uh getting rid
of that
wow well you sound sharper than a lot of
the 33 year olds that call into the show
so good for you man i'm proud of you so
you're wanting to follow the baby steps
you are you plugged into financial peace
university have your parents told you
about that
um i think we're going to be starting
that this year
awesome yeah i think we're going to be
starting this over break okay so you're
wondering what baby step you're on at 13
years old this is one of my favorite
questions in recent memory so you have
no debt obviously because you're 13.
gracious i hope we don't have 13 year
olds going into debt how much money do
you have to your name
um a little under a thousand dollars i
think wow
so you have a positive net worth you're
doing better than most of americans does
that feel pretty good
yes sir
so what are you doing for work how are
you getting this money
uh well i'm a saver and also i was on
the stock market a little wow so um
yeah this is impressive okay so on a
technical level you would be in baby
steps four through six
because you don't have debt now you
don't have your fully funded emergency
fund but right now you don't have
expenses you're 13. mom and dad are
covering the bills right
okay
so here's what i would tell you regard i
wouldn't worry too much about the baby
steps right now what i want you to do is
invest in titus and so i love that
you're already getting into the stock
market and understanding the stuff it
tells me that you're going to be
a multi-millionaire by the time you're
30 at most if you follow these steps
so do you know what you want to do
after high school
um i'm thinking about being an investor
of sorts like uh
on the stock market
and uh like you want to work on wall
street or whatever
um
you want to trade
um whether i don't know but whether it
be like stocks or online come on like
nfts
oh you're into nfts huh
well i don't know too much about them
but i think the future of investing is
shifting a little and so i'd like to
look more into modern things i love it
more modern stuff titus i'll tell you
what i learned because i i was like you
i was a curious teenager and i was going
what's the latest thing i want to keep
up and what i found now being 20 years
older than you is that if you follow the
trends you will fall for the traps and i
want you to avoid the traps at your age
so that you can build wealth and the
truth is things that are boring that
you've probably heard about like a 401k
and ira
mutual funds they're not as sexy as nfts
and crypto and all the things you're
probably
into but man the amount of millionaires
that have been created because of those
things the 401k the ira boring mutual
funds it is astronomical now show me all
the millionaires who bought nfts and
struck rich have you heard of these
people titus
no sir
agreed we are in agreement there so what
i want for you keep saving i love that
you're a saver also enjoy your life
you're 13. i don't want you to spend
your weekends trading stocks when you
could be hanging out with friends going
to the mall going to the movies just
doing normal 13 year old stuff do you do
that kind of stuff too
[Music]
um yes sir okay good good good you just
sound so smart that i'm like this guy
has a hard time having fun and so i know
some folks like that so i want you to
enjoy your teenage years also be very
curious about what you're into try a lot
of different things this is the time to
do that
up until after high school and you go
all right what's next do i want to be an
investor if you want to do that that
might be a career field because you're
going to have many years of experience
if you're already starting so i love
that for you the the key for me is stay
out of debt never touch it
can you do that for me titus sir
yes sir okay no matter how tempting it
sounds
don't touch student loans you don't need
a credit card you don't need to build
your credit score because at 13 if
you're listening to this stuff you're
gonna be able to pay cash for your first
home
is that a cool goal
yes sir i love that and then you don't
have a payment in the world so all the
income you have can go towards your true
love which is investing right
yes sir and then we're off to the races
so i love your spirit titus i appreciate
the call we're rooting for you and it
sounds like you're already going through
fpu otherwise i would gift it to you
love that call be encouraged america
there's 13 year olds that are sharper
than you when it comes to money wow we
all got to step up our game wells wesley
joins us in amarillo wesley welcome to
the show
hey george how you doing great how can i
help
well i i'm an owner operator uh truck
driver
and uh i have a
[Music]
a fairly new truck right now it's paid
for it's a it's a 20 20
and uh i'm completely debt free except
for my mortgage
and um
uh usually i've been in the habit of
trading trucks every three years
and uh with the way things are going
right now i'm wondering it's still a
smart idea i have one on order at the
moment
that i should be picking up in august
but i still have time to cancel
if i change my mind
now my new one
i can pay cash for
and after i sell this one with the way
the market is i'd probably be in the
hole about maybe between 60 and 80 000.
ouch but it would be completely paid for
there would be no borrowing of anything
in the hole you mean you would have to
shell out 80 grand in cash
yes okay but you have the cash
but i have the cash okay is this coming
out of your business revenue
yes okay yes
and on average my take-home per year on
average the last three years
has been about 200 000. wow that's your
take home you're crushing it man how old
are you
uh 43 i wish i was as smart as that 13
year old that just called though wow you
know like you're doing great man and
you're doing this all debt-free that's
impressive oh that's pretty i mean it's
taken a long time i've been on my own
i've been trucking for 25 years and i've
been on my own for almost 15
and i've moved up into the hazardous
materials uh hauling that's where the
money's at hazardous materials
yep nobody wants to deal with that yeah
no no nobody wants to take the chance of
blowing up they have a problem with it
for some reason okay so this new truck
is what's the benefit of moving up to
the new truck versus the one you have
it's a 20 20.
okay uh
from my knowledge the last 15 years it'd
be the the factor would be downtime
for this one i've noticed uh the last
three years i've only of each year
unscheduled downtime increases
by usually by 20 some percent and when
i'm down for a day or two of unscheduled
downtime it's a lot of money costing me
a thousand bucks yes it's costing me a
thousand bucks take home here's how i
look at it
i would upgrade so since you're doing it
with cash this is coming out of your
business expenses what i would do is can
i roi the 60 to 80 grand that i'm going
to be spending
and if you're telling me that it will
roi within a year or two i'd go ahead
and upgrade if you're doing it with cash
okay that feel right right
that sounds right i was just needing
i've been trying to call for the last
couple months because you're my final
final decision maker well it's a
blessing for both of us today wesley
thank you so much for the call love that
you're doing this completely debt-free
it makes me feel a whole lot better
you've got an incredible take-home pay
and if you keep doing that running your
business debt free you will be wildly
successful and build wealth thank you so
much for the call this is the ramsay
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five
listen inflation is affecting everyone
right now from the gas pump to the
grocery store and while you can't
control what happens with the economy
you can control what happens with your
money and the only way to control your
money in uncertain times is to get on a
budget and the best way to budget is
with every dollar you'll plan out your
monthly budget and track all of your
expenses throughout the month plus the
every dollar mobile app lets you check
your budget from anywhere so you can
always make the right money decisions
i'm telling you when you get on a budget
you'll be in total control of your money
start budgeting for free by going to
ramseysolutions.com
every dollar that's ramsey solutions dot
com slash every dollar
matt joins us up next in nashville
tennessee right down the road matt
welcome to the show
hey george how's it going great how are
you
going pretty good man i
appreciate you taking my call and thank
you it's an honor happy to do it what's
going on with you um
well so just real quick i wanted to ask
i i'm pretty sure i already know the
answer i guess just more so looking for
affirmation i guess but i got plenty of
that
my wife and i are um
are doing the baby steps together i went
through financial peace university
myself about three maybe four years ago
got myself out of debt one hundred
percent um awesome
started walking through it a second time
with my wife uh when we met in 2020
and she has paid off
a
very considerable amount of debt since
then but we're down to
down to the last one
so definitely see the light shining in
our face at the end of the tunnel
she her last debt is some student loans
um
less than 16 000 i think maybe 15 and
some change i think we're looking at
okay so we've got the savings to pay it
off but that would cut our savings
almost in half
and i know with times of inflation like
you were just talking about you know
uh god forbid if something were to
happen with when one of our jobs or
something you know
that you know
that savings
uh wouldn't carry us through as much
today as it would have a year maybe two
years ago so i'm kind of i'm a little
hesitant because it's a little scary uh
cutting our savings in half but then
again we would be 100 debt free
so i just wanted to hear your thoughts
on that yeah i understand matt that's a
tough one because right now you see
security in your savings account and i
see insecurity with these student loans
still around your necks and so the way i
look at it is this
that that money already has a name and
it's not yours right now it's navient
it's sallie mae it's whoever you owe
this student loan money to
and so when you deplete that savings
account that's not forever because
remember you now have freed up a student
loan payment and so now we can start
saving up real quick to get our fully
funded emergency fund in place which is
actually going to give you the security
you're looking for
so how much do you have in savings
so
we have two savings um i have we have a
house fund from the sale of her house
last year
uh
there's uh just shy of 80
k in that and then we have
we have a uh an emergency savings that
we've saved up and there's uh about 30
and some change in that
so you have 110 000 in liquid cash
and you're calling me over a 15 000
student loan debt that you want to keep
around i mean are you hearing yourself
yes
yes sir i am
okay well the good news is this is a
good problem to have because the student
loans are gone today and you still have
95 000
does that not give you security
it does uh i mean
we were saving 86 of that to
uh i'm sorry we were saving a large
chunk of that toward down payment on a
new house but whenever
whenever the market quits being stupid
we uh
we're actively looking with our realtor
right now but um we're constantly being
outbid by people coming over from
different parts of the country and now
bidding us locals so that's the
nashville we
we've kind of decided just to hold off
on looking for a house right now sit
tight we're in a we're in a very nice
apartment in a very safe neighborhood
right now
so we're not in a position where we have
to make a hasty desperate decision so
we're just going to sit tight on that
for the next year or so
and continue to build on that house fund
perfect so if you paid off the loans
today you have 95 000 you keep stacking
money on top of that of course uh part
of that's your emergency fund so we're
leaving that alone but that puts you in
3b today if you paid it off which means
you're saving up for that down payment
you'll have a six-figure down payment i
assume that's at least 10 percent of
whatever you're looking at buying right
20 percent probably
uh it'd be between 25 and 30 percent uh
given our max budget this is a great
place to be matt i have no hesitation in
paying off these loans today
okay even with no interest or whatever
it is
yeah absolutely man good luck come do
your debt-free scream that'll be a fun
one
all right brett joins us up next in
atlanta georgia brett welcome to the
show
hey george thanks for taking my call
today absolutely what's going on
yeah so i've heard the
the study of the 10 000 millionaires and
how they're all able to pay off their
loans quickly and that's how they i
guess credit themselves to becoming a
millionaire uh my question is
basically i can't wrap my head around
how it mathematically makes sense to pay
off
super low interest rate loans versus
paying all of that overage money to buy
stock that's currently on sale today i
know that there's risk involved but i'm
27 years old
my wife and i we both work and i rarely
look at my stock account whether the
market is up or down i just
don't care i guess i'm risk adverse um
so i can definitely go into some of the
scenario about where we are at in life
how much we're making how much we have
saved up how much loans
uh right now two car loans at thirty
seven thousand at a one point nine eight
percent fixed interest rate rental
property loan at a hundred and forty
thousand at a three point two five
percent fixed interest rate and then
personal home mortgage loan of 185 000
at 2.75 fixed interest rate okay what's
your
household income
anywhere between 250 to 300 000 a year i
love it well you've got a nice big
shovel that helps with everything
definitely so
your question was why would i pay off
the loans when i could just invest all
that money
yeah the overage i mean i'm 27 so i'm
guessing 30 plus years of compound
interest working it's magic so at 27
let's just say you didn't have a payment
in the world how many what do your
payments all add up to on your mortgage
your rental property the car payments
uh monthly payment of one car is 460
another monthly payment is 565.
rental property
payment is 9.50 and then home mortgage
is 1075.
okay so about three thousand let's call
that three grand what i want you to do
is go to a compound interest calculator
and put three grand in there
every month
for the next 40 years
tell me what that adds up to
and then tell me do you want to keep
those loans around or is that money
better off invested
okay i think i win
i'm playing the tortoise game you're
playing the hair game and that's fine
you know i'm not mad you're still going
to be a millionaire we'll get there
different ways but the way to do it
without risk and with a little more
financial peace which let me tell you as
you get older and you start having a
family all those loans hanging around
aren't going to add any security to your
life
now you can do it brett's way and
honestly you'll be fine you're a sharp
dude at 27 you know a thing or two but
as for me in my house we just don't do
payments that's a value that we've
adopted early on and it's it's an
identity thing for me it's not about
math it's about the kind of person i am
is the kind of guy who doesn't need to
answer to anybody and when i don't have
a payment in the world which i don't
because i paid off my house in december
man i'm a light as a feather come at me
bro
if i lost my job today which god willing
if the show goes well dave doesn't do
i'm okay i have an emergency fund i
don't owe anyone anything and so that's
the kind of mindset that i want you to
have you don't have to have it you don't
have to share all my values but you
called into the show and asked me for my
opinion and you got it and it's worth
what you paid for my friend thanks for
the call this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell you're listening to
the ramsay show
i'm looking out to an empty lobby right
now it's real sad so this is your
friendly reminder to come visit us
that's right here at the headquarters of
ramsey solutions we're about 30 minutes
south of wonderful nashville tennessee
and when you enter this place it is rare
air it's special you smell the cookies
being baked we've got free baked goods
free coffee a free mug
whoever's hosting the show will come out
twice an hour for photos sign books say
hey we love to meet people who travel
from all over the country to come see us
or make a pit stop on their way we've
got kind of the wall of the museum wall
if you will where you can kind of check
out the history of ramsay solutions the
team did an incredible job crafting an
experience for our fans who want to
visit celebrate with us along their
money journey so go to
ramseysolutions.com
visit let us know you're coming we'll
get you all the details who's going to
be here what's going on we would love to
have you wherever you are in the world
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
to call let me help you take the right
next step with your money and your life
jason has decided to do that he's in
kansas city jason welcome to the show
yeah thanks for having me i appreciate
it george absolutely what's going on
with you
so really quick me and my wife were you
know i'm 50 going to be 52 she's 50
going to be 51
we're kind of live bootstrapping uh baby
step 5 with my daughter going to college
right now
and we got an extra 600 a month that we
started
putting on our house payment because we
were thinking that we wanted to have the
house paid off
in five years but my interest rate's two
and a quarter and i'm starting to wonder
if maybe that six hundred dollars
might be better off put in to you know
our investment because we're you know
we're kind of new to it so we only got
about 54 saves between our uh matches
and our roths being completely maxed out
um and that's between the two of you
yeah between the two of us okay
and what's left on the house 66. oh
okay well we're not we're not far away
uh on the house there what's your
household income
um it's about 115.
okay love it
now
you're saying should i be investing that
extra 600 bucks instead of putting it
towards the house are you already
investing 15 percent of your household
income
yes yes we are we're we're both fully
matched we're we're fully on the match
with our employers and we're
putting in
7 500 each on our roth
okay well that's good news and is
college paid for are we still in the
trenches of that no we're we're live
bootstrapping our daughter through
college she just finished her first year
she's paying half and we're paying half
because
she understands the importance of coming
out of this without any student loans on
the other end i love it that's what i
was going to ask is there any way she
could pitch in more so that you guys can
let your foot off that gas pedal and
move towards paying off the house and
investing
probably not just because she is you
know living out on her own too
and i would i would much rather
even though it would you know hurt us a
little bit funny so i would much rather
make sure that i'm you know helping her
get to that level that i i wasn't able
to get to you know yeah
well i found and this it's a sad
situation that happens more often than
i'd like but
students graduate because mom and dad
helped them get through college debt
free but mom and dad didn't prepare for
retirement they didn't pay off the home
and now the children are stuck trying to
help the adults retire because they
didn't prepare for themselves so there's
a 50 50 shot that she grabbed i think
she's going to graduate she sounds like
a real sharp uh lady but there's a 100
chance that you guys need to retire and
so i want you to make sure you put your
own mask on first and uh that still
leaves us with your original question
should i be investing extra beyond the
15 i would still be putting that towards
the house and the question is can you
pay that off in earlier than five years
from now now you're putting what 7 200
extra on the house payment
right
we're like we refinanced and we got it
down to two and a quarter
and then that refinance making it 15
making it a 15-year note you know we
were able to still
uh figure out in our budget how to get
an additional 600 on top of the house
payment yeah
well i still like the idea of using that
towards the house payment and finding
ways to speed that process up even
faster because investing 15 for the next
you know five years while you pay off
the house you're still going to be in a
good spot and you won't have a mortgage
payment and so it's going to be a lot
easier to retire because your expenses
just went way down what's your mortgage
payment
um it's like
it's around nine but you know obviously
that's half and half right i mean uh
some of that's the actual loan and then
some of it's like the escrow
you know for the insurance and the
property that's all baked in there well
here's what i like to do when i want to
get fired up about this mortgage go pull
up the amortization schedule and look at
how much is going towards interest
versus the principal and as you get
towards the end man it feels good
because almost every penny is actually
hitting that principle paying your debt
down and so the advice here doesn't
change um you guys aren't in dire
straits i mean i want you to have you
know a million dollars in retirement and
that might mean you work longer than you
want to do you plan on working for
another decade or two oh yeah yeah i'm a
busy busy kind of guy i do do a lot of
side stuff with consulting and stuff
like that too so nice well i'd keep that
going i'd increase the side hustles i'd
do everything i could to make sure the
house is paid off and i'm investing and
once you get to baby step seven you can
increase that investing you can start
investing 25 30 if you want to um to
catch up and at your age you'll be able
to do some of those catch-up
contributions in your 401k and ira and
so if you keep hustling another 10-15
years you're gonna be able to retire and
i want you guys to retire as
millionaires with a paid for house and i
think that's still possible for you and
uh we'll let the kids figure out how
they're going to pay for college
debt-free but you raise some good ones
so i'm not too worried about that
appreciate the call alex joins us up
next in saint augustine florida alex
welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me what's going on
so i recently sold my home in
chattanooga to move back to florida
and right around the time that i was
selling it i learned about you guys and
figured out that i had a brand new truck
that i did not need
that's a good reason
so now i'm trying to sell that truck but
when i bought this truck i had gone
in with another trade that i was upside
down on and even in today's market i'm
currently eight thousand dollars
under in this loan
and i have another new car that my wife
drives and
that one is not
in the same situation i i owe 18 on it
and they'll give me 19 for it but the
truck i currently have i owe 38 on it
and uh they're pretty much giving me 30
or 31 for it wow so it's a brand new
truck
it's a 2019 f-150 okay i feel like you
can get more for it where did you go
have you checked seven places have you
checked carvana of room local
dealerships have you done your due
diligence there
i've checked about three different
dealers um and they all say the same
amount actually um carvana offered me 27
for it so well that's because caravan is
broke right now so they're not doing too
hot
but i would keep checking i would check
what you could get private party for it
and uh can you get rid of your wife's
car then
well that's the thing that if if i get
rid of her car her car payment is only
340 a month my car payment is 615 a
month oh i'm not impressed with amounts
of car payments i want you guys to just
be debt-free and get some beaters what's
your income
75 000 um and my wife doesn't work she's
a stay-at-home mom oh my
goodness yeah but that that should
change in this come august when my
youngest one is uh finally going to
kindergarten so
uh we'll be sending her off to school my
wife will have free time so she plans to
to get a job but in the meantime i was
hoping to use the summer to get rid of
these cars and we could get rid of my
wife's car and get her something more
affordable
um like like you say be there for a
couple of months but how much money do
you have in the bank
i have about 9 000 left over from the
side of my house after paying off about
32 000 dollars in credit card debt that
we have
how much other debt do you have
um i just have these two cars and a 7
500
personal loan okay
here's what here's what i would do if i
was in your shoes you have 9 000 and so
you're not you're upside down 8k but you
could cover it and so it's not fun i'm
still trying to get the best deal for
this car that i can uh but i'm selling
both of these cars dude you make 70k and
you have 50 000 tied up in cars that's
just too much car so i'm getting rid of
both cars get something reasonable maybe
5 000 a piece i know it's not going to
be fun to drive not going gonna be as
flashy as the ones you got but that will
get you out of this along with the cash
you have in the bank
and then we can breathe and get rid of
this person alone and move on with our
lives and never touch debt again
appreciate the call that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
can be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to being well i'm george
campbell your host and i'm flying solo
today so give me a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you need a little bit of
motivation a lot of people calling for
affirmation they think they know what to
do they just need someone to tell them
it's the right move i'm happy to help
you do that triple eight eight two five
five two two five brady kicks off this
hour in dallas texas brady welcome to
the show
hey george what's up man you're killing
it flying solo today i appreciate that
vote of confidence thank you i'll make
sure dave here hears that comment
what's going on with you well hey
good man good i've got a a real estate
question for you my wife and i are both
uh 27 years old we've got two little
kids a three-year-old and that
two-month-old and for the past five
years we have been airbnb hosts um but
the catch is we haven't owned the
properties that we've airbnb we've done
rental arbitrage where uh
give us permission
to rent out their place right so we've
done this for five years and it's gone
great it's super fun we just save save
save pile up cash don't touch any of it
but we don't have any equity in those
properties and so my question is the
place we live right now we actually
don't own as well we rent
but it's so dirt cheap and we love it so
much that we don't really want to move
anywhere but we desperately want to buy
a house so that we can have equity
in you know a hard asset so my question
really would be
i know obviously with
ramsey plan and the baby steps like we
were supposed to pay off your primary
residence first if we love where we live
so much right now we're saving so much
money because it's so cheap could we
possibly buy an investment property
first
and just pay that off aggressively while
we still rent where we live
i don't see anything wrong with that so
what's your rent right now
our rent is just 1200 bucks a month but
we're on like 11 acres and a great house
and it's really quiet and super
beautiful what's your household income
uh it fluctuates i'm self-employed so
it's anywhere between 200 to 300. wow
great income that's awesome are you
working full-time while doing these
airbnb hosting
yes yeah we are okay
well
i'm okay with you doing this but it
doesn't sound like you're are you going
to pay cash for this piece of property
no we're not going to pay cash we would
probably get like a 15-year fixed
mortgage like you guys recommend
and we typically would i mean we'd
obviously put 20 down do all that we've
been aggressively paying for the down
payment um and we're ready to pull the
trigger we just don't we're just kind of
torn on what we should do
yeah what i don't like is now you're
paying two housing payments a month
right and you can float it with your
income but i'm also going well why
couldn't you pay cash with an income
like that
what's stopping you guys from just
piling up a bunch of money where's all
the money going right now
i mean we're just saving it so it's
either going to retirement or
um it's just kind of sitting in a
checking account and you guys are
completely debt free
yes totally with no mortgage payment
because you're renting or
right yeah i mean how quickly could you
scrape up enough cash to just buy it
outright
i mean it would definitely take another
probably a year two years i mean again
just with the market being absolutely
astronomical right now i mean you can
get like a double wide for three hundred
thousand dollars you know and so
that's why
you know in order for it to be an
attractive rental that's an airbnb it's
kind of hard to just
pay cash for anything that isn't a dump
yeah i just with investment property you
have increased risk because
ideally we have people staying in it
constantly but
as we know that's not always the case
and you have one you know another
variant of
covid comes out and all of a sudden no
one's traveling and all of a sudden your
airbnb is sitting there and you're still
making the mortgage payment and so i
just don't like that increased risk in
your life while trying to pay your now
you you have a very reasonable rent
comparatively to your income but i also
just want to challenge you and go a year
is not that far away man you're 27 years
old you're crushing it you're making 300
grand you could save up for a year and
have a little bit of patience i think
what's happening it now proved me wrong
but you're getting a little starry-eyed
right at the upside of yeah my own
property and we're building that equity
and someone's running it out and all you
see is the upside and you kind of delete
the risk out of your brain
right thank you so much i i really
appreciate it yeah i think i definitely
have had like a starry eyed
you know i just i hate not owning an
asset that has equity in it so i just i
feel like i need to really park it into
something that's stable you know so
that's why i've kind of gotten a little
bit impatient but if i said hey man 12
months from now you can have 100 equity
and every dime that comes in is all
yours
and you're not hoping you net enough
profit to cover the mortgage plus a
little more and so that's what i want
for you as a 27 year old you got two
kids i want you to leave a legacy i
don't want you to have stress hanging
out in your life i'm are you so low
income does your wife work outside the
home
uh no solo income we both kind of run
our own business so we support each
other and do our own thing yeah awesome
when you're a sharp young couple i'm
just going dude you make 300 grand could
you live off a hundred and stack away
two
yeah that's true to me i'm not
fluctuating i'm self-employed sure i
mean that's high years you know but it
sounds like you also can kind of create
as much income as you hustle for
yes that's true and so to me i'm gonna
dangle that carrot and go man how cool
would it be to pay cash for my first
investment property and eventually i do
want you to have your own place i know
you're paying 1200 bucks and it's a
great spot but i also want you to have a
fixed expense because that rent can go
up at any time and we've seen that
happen in this market where people are
calling us going my rent went up 67 what
do i do
you don't have that when you own the
place
yeah that's true so long term i want you
to also look into getting a primary
residence and later on dude you got your
whole life ahead of you to get into the
investing world and so if i'm you i
might save up pay cash for my primary
residence if you want to do that
okay and then you get the world is your
oyster because now you don't have that
1200 a month payment in your life and
now you can save up real quick to get
that next investment property
that's true man that's true okay i
really appreciate it that definitely
gives you something to think about
that's what that's what i'm here for
just giving you something to chew on
brady way to go man that's an impressive
guy right there making two 300k
uh running airbnb hosting now the rental
arbitrage what he was explaining this is
an interesting phenomenon i just learned
about this this is where you rent a
place out and you go to the landlord and
say hey do you mind if i basically
sublease this place as an airbnb
now the amount of landlords who will say
yes to that they're few and far between
because they don't want that liability
in their life of strangers being in and
out of their property and you're the one
making a profit off of it so this is a
rare situation brady's lucked out in
this case and i hope it works out for
him he's got five under his belt which
is impressive but he's upset because he
doesn't have the equity because he
doesn't own the place and that's one of
the biggest problems with rental
arbitrage
so if you want to get into real estate
investing here's what we teach here's
what we've always taught for many many
years
pay off your primary residence first
then pay cash for investment properties
i know that sounds like a million years
away to most of you who want to be
investing gurus but guess what it's the
way you're going to do it without going
broke it's the way you're going to do it
with financial peace without that risk
in your life especially
as you have a family you've got young
kids
man
what if they could grow up completely
debt-free
and never see their parents struggle
with money that's the kind of life i
want for my family
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast you can check out
both of those shows on the ramsey
network or wherever you listen to
podcasts
so when the team gets together at ramsey
solutions we talk a lot about our
mission to change america's toxic money
culture it makes us mad to see people
get trapped by debt or to watch kids
sign away their future for a student
loan
and for the folks who work here this is
not a j.o.b
it's a mission to change lives so if
that sounds like a passion that you
share which if you're listening to this
show that might be you you've got to
check out all of the exciting roles
ramsay solutions is looking to fill asap
there's never been a better time to find
a job doing work you love and we need
good folks out there who care deeply who
are very talented so we need developers
we need ux designers we need writers to
help us build digital products that
actually change people's lives we don't
do widgets around here we do hope
you can check out what it's like to do
work that matters with us before you
apply you can follow us on instagram and
facebook by searching ramsey careers our
hr team here some incredible folks who
are always inspiring people giving you
some behind the scenes of what it's
really like if you've wondered what's it
like to be part of this team with over
1100 people now doing work that matters
i know you thought we did this out of a
double wide but we've got
hundreds of developers alone our tech
team is gigantic we've got writers we
have designers we have copy editors we
have customer care folks we have
lots of lots of different roles and so
if you have talent in those areas and
you care about this mission you want to
help people go check out
ramseysolutions.com
career your dream job could be just
around the corner ramsay solutions dot
com slash careers
open phones this hour the number to call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let me help you take the right next
step with your money and your life
angela joins us up next in los angeles
angela welcome to the show
hi thank you george how are you i'm
doing great what's going on with you
well i am a 23 year old mom and i have
two little ones they're two and one
years old i'm currently on baby step two
so i've already completed my first baby
step a thousand dollars of emergency
fund awesome and i've been listening to
the show for like three weeks i want to
say now and i i love it so thank you
absolutely um
i have a total of 23 000 in debt
student loans credit cards and a car
payment and i have an income right now
of 47 000. okay
but the only part that i feel isn't
the best is the work environment i'm in
right now it is toxic it is a little
mom-and-pop shop and i feel like it's
literally draining me every day so i've
been applying to different positions and
i recently got a call from the school
district
saying that they're very interested in
me and are ready to give me an offer but
when i asked about the pay the pay is
about
seven thousand dollars
less than what i make right now
so they're offering 40 and you're making
47. and you're going should i take this
to get out of a toxic situation while
i'm in debt
yes
now are there any other reasons other
than the salary that you're looking at
this job
yes there is um the current job that i'm
at again it is a mom-and-pop shop so the
benefits aren't fair yet like the days
off sick pay stuff like that
um i don't have a retirement plan which
is something that i'm really bummed out
about
and
i also don't have the health insurance
or it's not the best health insurance
but they take out a big amount from my
paycheck so i opted out of it oh you
opted out so do you not have health
health insurance right now
no just my kids but my kids have it
through their father yeah okay i would
get health insurance today
okay that's a scary situation to be in
because we've seen too many sad
situations where people bankrupt over
medical bills
yes so i want you to make sure you get
that taken care of
our folks can help ramsay solutions.com
click on trusted pros we've got health
insurance pros that can help walk you
through what your options are
to make sure that you're taken care of
there so let's talk about the job okay
are you moving into a different career
field or is it the same type of work
no right now i'm in
it's the manufacturing side of things
but i would be going to a school
district so
kind of the same but it's all clerical
work okay
my question is are there other jobs out
there that could pay you 47 000 or more
so that you're not taking a dip in
income
um i want to say yes but because i don't
have a degree they're not going to pay
me what i
get paid now i live in the outskirts of
los angeles so
it's hard to get the same pay have you
let the school district know hey i
appreciate the offer so much you know i
was making 47 i don't know that i can
make the jump down to 440 by taking this
roll is there any way you can meet me
would they be willing to do that
i did ask if they were going to be
raises and i guess after a six month
graduational period it gives me a few
spent but it's stages
so that would be the first stage it'd be
a few cents okay on top of that yeah
well uh you know benefits are something
to take into consideration when you take
into the cost of health care on your own
versus the school district which i
imagine has a much better uh health care
program
then you might go you know what i'm
gonna be paying seven thousand dollars
out of pocket for all these benefits and
so i'm okay taking this hit because the
net result is not slowing me down for my
debt snowball
does that make sense
yes
so i'm not saying don't take it but i
would proceed with caution make sure
that you've looked at all your options
look at what their healthcare program is
look at what it would cost you right now
to get health care and whatever other
benefits uh you don't have that might be
covered to see how that would affect
your net income because i don't want you
to slow down your debt snowball so the
question is if we take this job how do
we not slow down the debt snowball could
you do side hustles i know are you a
single mom
uh no i have my partner okay beyonce so
child care is taken care of
yes okay
i would see if there's any side hustles
to make up the gap temporarily um and
then see if maybe you take a different
job six months from now as you keep
exploring to get your income up i don't
want you to just stay at 40 regardless
of okay if you have debt or not
especially living even remotely if you
can throw a rock near la that's an
expensive place to live even on the
outskirts
and so i want you to get that income up
as high as possible uh are you and your
partner sharing expenses how does this
work um
so again i started listening to you guys
like i want to say three weeks ago and
i've been telling him about it but he's
still not open to the idea of
joining our account or anything so right
now it's just me and then it's just him
he takes care of his stuff and i take
care of his stuff but when it comes to
like the kids we both combine okay and
he's a father
yeah okay
well i'll i want him to have more skin
in the game here i mean we're not
playing roommates we had kids together
so let's step it up
and uh let's have him go through
financial peace university it's gonna be
my gift to you guys your job is gonna be
going hey
we're not okay right now we're in a
scary place i want this dead out of my
life will you go through this nine
lesson video course have some
conversations and actually plug into it
put the phones away and just dial in
would he be willing to do that
i'm sure he would
okay so if you hang on the line i'll
have austin pick up we're gonna gift you
guys financial peace university and
every dollar premium that's our
budgeting tool i want you guys to get on
a written budget for all of your
expenses
and
that's going to all be inside of ramsey
plus there's a lot of tools and
resources for you there
but my goal for you is to not slow down
the debt snowball because right now
you're paying off this 23 000 in debt
how much is the car worth
uh 11 000
okay
and what do you owe on it
um
i want to save the 11 000. i just got it
not that long ago oh okay
so yeah you could clean that up but
you're gonna turn around and have to get
another car for probably six
thousand
so it accelerated slightly
yeah okay well keep tackling are you
doing the debt snowball listing out
smallest to largest
yes i
i currently have all my things written
out and i've been attacking them so far
everything's been going good and i can
read a little
good that's what i want for you angela
breathing room margin that's what this
program this plan is all about so hang
on the line austin will pick up we'll
gift you guys ramsey plus for one year
that includes all the videos in
financial peace university and every
dollar premium our budgeting tool if you
do this stuff and you get him on board
it's going to really help out the
process
that's my hope for you and good luck
with the job transition as you make that
jump and please please for the love get
healthcare everyone listening if you
don't have health insurance get it today
there's no reason to bankrupt on health
insurance on medical bills it's a
dangerous situation this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
i'm george campbell you're listening to
the ramsay show
if you don't know me i've been on the
ramsay team now for nine years i feel
like i grew up here
and when i started i had a negative net
worth i had a bunch of student loan debt
i racked up some credit card debt and i
went through financial peace university
when i first started here as an intern
an attempt and it absolutely changed my
life got out of debt in 18 months met my
wife here who works here at ramsey
solutions beautiful love story we'll
save for another time and back in
december we paid off our mortgage
reaching the elusive baby step seven
at uh 32 and 30 years old and let me
tell you it was worth it it's worth it
all the sacrifice to get out of debt to
get rid of your mortgage payment to
invest for the future to have the
emergency fund it's worth it in case
you're wondering if this ramsay plan
stuff is really worth all the sacrifice
and all the trouble when you could do it
your way but here's what i found my way
wasn't working i thought george's plan
was fancy i thought i was smarter than
the system and i was there to beat the
system and it turns out the system is
rigged against you and so a better way
to do it is to just rise above the
system
and once i did that i realized oh i
don't need a credit score
that's right because a credit score just
allows you to get more debt and if we're
saying no to debt then we don't need a
credit score and so we got our mortgage
through a process called manual
underwriting because we didn't have a
credit score we got a 15-year fix we had
a big down payment and we paid it off in
26 months and now we're free in our
early 30s on our way to baby steps
millionaire status
and so my hope for you
is that you feel the same hope that you
feel inspired to follow this plan to
maybe come here and do your debt-free
scream one day to be baby steps
millionaires to live and give like no
one else that's what dave ramsey's been
teaching for years and that's what i'm
here to help you do today so give me a
call triple eight eight two five
five two two five barbara joins us up
next in philadelphia barbara welcome to
the show
thanks george for taking my call i just
have a question my husband and i are in
our mid 70s and unfortunately we just
started investing
about two and a half years ago we
just wasn't sure about the market so we
never really got into it but we were
trying to save as much as possible and
i'm just trying to figure out with what
we have now
how
how we can live
uh to be comfortable if we are living
comfortable now with what we do have
okay what's your income
uh well we clear we're both retired
about 10 years we are we clear about 75
000 a year we're debt free
our home is worth about 600 000
and we have um about 125 000 that we did
take and invest just two years ago and
we have about 25 to 28 000 in savings
right now
and um we don't have any debt
trying to figure all that out okay so
your home is paid for no mortgage
payment
no so you've done really well except
that you haven't invested
because you've got some money saved the
house is paid off which means your
expenses are
really low i assume right right they're
about 14 to 1500 a month okay so at 1500
bucks a month multiply that out you're
going to have some margin left over
you're telling me that your expenses are
about 18 grand and you're pulling 75
right
which tells me we can invest a whole big
chunk of that because you could live
another what 20 25 years
lord willing yes lord willing the creek
don't rise
and so
do you feel comfortable right now what's
kind of got you worried
uh just the fact that we should have
been saving a long time ago we spent a
lot of money just helping our family out
our kids out for weddings graduations
and stuff like that we took some trips
here and there of things we enjoy and
did things
and we just came across you guys a
couple years ago
and uh just by listening on the radio
while we were traveling sorry we didn't
catch you before now but we did buy a
car last year for 38 000 that we paid
cash for we wondered if that was the
best thing we should have done whether
we should keep it or or still keep it or
maybe sell it get something less or what
so is that your one car
uh we have we have a truck that's been
paid for for a number of years okay
i mean comparatively to your
your income it is a lot it's a lot of
car we recommend uh no more than half of
your annual income be tied up and things
with motors in it because they're going
down in value
and so you can't take the hit as much
when it's you know you're making 75 and
your cars are worth 50.
yeah
yeah
so and we do have some um we have a few
antique cars that
we thought about you know if we needed
to sell in the future we could we enjoy
them and that's another question that we
were trying to figure out now we just
want to make sure that we're covered
pretty well
that we don't have to worry and that our
family can take care of themselves now
and and we can just you know continue to
save them like you say invest some best
more yeah is this income all coming from
social security and pensions
right okay
well you're not in dire straits i mean
yes you haven't invested as much as i
would have liked but you also have a
paid for home you have an emergency fund
and you have this income coming in
that's you know guaranteed for now
right
and so you're not in a terrible
situation what i would do is make sure
that long-term you know with long-term
care do you have that in place
um no
okay what i don't want for you is all
your money is depleted within two years
because you know one day god forbid
you're in a nursing home and it costs a
hundred grand a year
right and all of a sudden the kids are
trying to work here we are healthy we
stay we try to stay healthy we don't
have any medical issues
uh so we we just enjoy life as we can
and just trying to you know make every
day count and try to save as much as we
can for the future
and that so i just wonder you know i
love your advice i know you're giving
good advice
and i just want to find out exactly
where we do stand from what you're
saying now yeah i mean i would just do a
budget every month there's only three
things you can do with that money give
save spend so i'd allocate as much as
you'd like to giving 10 is a good
baseline beyond that make sure you're
saving as much as you can and investing
that money don't leave it sitting out in
the checking account because you're
scared of the market because in 20 years
of riding the wave your money will grow
and so don't get scared
yeah we did have some in the money
market which wasn't like getting
anything for a number of years
and then that's what we took and saved
to invest what we did to have the 125
000 we have now that we're investing
okay keep that invested are you working
with a financial advisor
uh yes we are okay good make sure you've
got a trustworthy advisor in your corner
because especially your age you've got
to be very wise with this money and so i
don't want you know the market to to
take a dip and you get spooked and take
all the money out and now it's not even
beating inflation and you need this
money long term for retirement so i
don't think you're in a terrible
situation but you may have to adjust
your expectations of what retirement
would have been could have been should
have been
you may not be able to go on extravagant
vacations every year but you can still
cover all your bills suck enough away in
investing
and spend someone enjoy it
all right so as long as you feel good
about it appreciate it yeah absolutely
thank you so much for the call barbara
that's that's an interesting situation
where you've got a paid for home you've
got money in the bank for the emergency
fund but you haven't done a great job of
investing so i want to encourage
everyone out there listening
um barbara's done a great job they could
have done better on the investing side
but when you don't have a mortgage
payment and you have an emergency fund
it changes the situation
and obviously they have social security
and pensions but let me tell you young
folks out there like me i just saw a
headline that saying social security
will be depleted by 2033.
well
sucks for me doesn't it
especially sucks because i've been
paying social security out of every
paycheck since i've been working and i
don't get to see the fruits of all that
money that the government handled so
wisely
they're so good at that aren't they
so do not depend on social security
don't even depend on your pension
because those can go bankrupt that's not
a guarantee for life i want you to have
the ball in your corner which means
you're investing your own money into
401ks and iras and good growth stock
mutual funds diversified across four
types like we teach
that is what is going to give you
security
don't rely on the white house don't rely
on one single company to cover your
retirement i want you to retire with
dignity to leave a legacy to leave an
inheritance to your children's children
that's the kind of life i want for you
and you can get there and if you're 60
you still got time and if you're 20 you
have even more time but quit fooling
around
avoid the traps be consistent live on
less than you make don't let lifestyle
creep take over your income it's those
kinds of things that will allow you to
build wealth not the white house not
nfts not crypto nothing fancy do boring
consistent stuff and you'll be okay
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell your host today you
are listening to the ramsay show give me
a call triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll talk about your
life and your money
maria joins us in california maria
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much for taking my call
it's such an honor to speak with you i'm
honored to take it how you doing
doing okay i've got a tricky situation
with my mom
that i just need some help deciphering
through okay
about seven eight years ago
my mom lives off of social security
she's been disabled for about 25 years
she sold a home in las vegas and had the
cash for a down payment but
she had no
monthly income so she could not get a
home loan on her own
she proposed to me
to get a house together so we did here
in
california
she put the down payment me and my
husband have been making the mortgage
utilities repairs on the house all these
years
recently she's made some comments
uh that she wants her own space which
our family my husband's family we have
kids our families growing so we all kind
of need our own space now
but her comment that got me
kind of swirling into a frenzy is that
she wants
to leave her portion of the house to
me and my siblings when she passes so
me and my husband are kind of like
yeah we don't want to keep putting money
into a house that we may have to part
with
eventually
um
so i guess i'm just wondering
how would i buy her out
or do i just sell and do we just kind of
go our separate ways that way because
she is only living off of social
security income
and um
yeah that's basically it i just know
that she wants to leave something to my
siblings when she passes and i didn't
know that she was using the property to
do that
originally so is she wanting to leave
the property itself or the proceeds from
the property the equity the proceeds
okay
so you have no problem getting out of
this house do you do you want to stay
there if she leaves
i would like to stay there because we
got such a great deal on it back in
2015
but um
i'm not like really emotionally attached
i'm okay with leaving if they have to i
just want to make sure i do right by her
and right by my husband
so
well i think if you're saying to me you
want to stay in this house but you want
to buy her out of it is her name on the
title or the mortgage
nope just me
so do you have an agreement in writing
that says she has part ownership of this
house
there's no agreement in writing no it's
just
a verbal agreement between me and her so
what is her involvement financially in
this property right now what is there to
buy her out of
i guess the down payment she put down
so she put the down payment down so
would she be okay just getting the down
payment amount back or is she wanting a
percentage of equity
i think she is wanting a percentage of
equity
from what it sounds like
and i don't know how that works so
that's well you never put anything in
writing which makes it a whole lot more
complicated because now i mean how i
feel versus how she feels and what's
enough and you know what what was the
down payment versus what was the
property worth when you got it
so it was worth uh
360 000.
she put i think
uh
about 180 down
wow
so she has i mean 50 is really what she
put down
do you think it's fair to give her 50
equity of what it's currently worth
i do i'm i'm a i mean i think that's
fair i don't because she's only living
off of social security i know she
doesn't
have
much so it sounds like she's not in a
place to leave anything to anyone
because she's broke yeah it sounds like
she needs them
that's true because here's what happens
you give her the money that then goes to
you and the siblings and then you and
the siblings now need to have the money
to pay for her
because she can't afford to live
and so and if we did split ways
one one of us siblings would have to get
another loan for her because she still
doesn't have an income to get her own
does she have disabilities
uh disability and social security yes
okay and that adds up to what
about
1300 a month
so where is she gonna go if she moves
out
i've been trying to
get her to think about that
and i think she realizes
what a sweet deal she has living with me
right now
since i'm pretty much paying for
everything but neither of you want this
situation to continue it sounds like
i mean
i think we gotta figure out where she's
gonna go before we kick her out
no totally and that's also why we've
kind of been dragging our feet is
because i don't think she really has
anywhere to go unless we were to sell
and she could buy something cash
that's my feeling is that you guys might
need to sell or do a cash out refi if
not just to give her the money she needs
to survive
so i don't know we might be forced into
an option because she has not done a
great job of taking care of herself is
she able to work at all
no
not nothing from work from home or
anything like that
um
nothing she's on medication
and sits in her room all day that's also
um
something that bothers my husband and
but i mean
it's my mom so i don't know yeah
it's not an issue of of laziness i just
want her to have some purpose to wake up
every morning and so if that's even a
part-time
job remotely that she can do from home i
think she needs that how old is she
uh she's she'll be 70 this year okay
but she has her wits about her i feel
like she could do some freelance illegal
stuff she used to work in a law office
and i've really tried to push her to do
that but
she's got to use her brain at least
so what's the house worth currently
right now um i haven't gotten an
appraisal or anything but
when i did a refi
last year
it was about seven hundred thousand
wow that's good news
yes
and how much cash do you guys have
outside of the home do you have liquid
savings
me and my husband do we have about
twenty five thousand okay and that's
your emergency fund i assume
okay
yeah i mean to get her the money she
needs you would have to do a cash out
refi and it's less complicated because
her name's not on the title or the
mortgage so the only reason to do the
refi and cash out is to give her the
money so that she has a place to live
um and again i would try to find
something to pay cash so that she
doesn't have any fixed expenses and
she's able to just use that 1300 to you
know eat and have basic needs but
there's no extravagance here she's not
retiring and having a great time this is
going to be bare bones because what i
don't want is you and the siblings to
have to cover her life uh for the next
you know 20 years we don't know how long
she'll live so we've got to have a plan
in place to get her taken care of okay
okay okay that's a conversation you need
to have with her and have you had that
hard conversation where you go mom
you're broke and i want you to be able
to have your own place but you can't
afford it
right so what does this look like
and i'm okay if she
i'm okay if she stays
with me my husband have talked about
that like
if we bought her out
she could still stay with us i just want
her to understand this is
our home you know i don't want to have
to
yeah i don't want any resentment
bubble up over this either
right
all right all right i'm so sorry you're
going through that down for me yeah it's
a tough situation there's no easy happy
ending for a lot of people here
um which
brings me to my next point
take care of yourself people because i
don't want your kids to have to do it
for you i don't want to have to take
care of my parents i'm happy to do it
because i love them and they've worked
so hard to provide for me but putting
your kids in a situation where you're a
burden to them is not going to be fun
for anyone
especially as they try to build wealth
and live their financial lives and we're
turning around and trying to fill the
leak over here because mom didn't do a
great job investing for the future
making sure she had a plan in place and
so that's not a knock here i just i just
want everyone to have a plan to retire
with dignity and you can do it but it's
going to take some hard work some
sacrifices some hard conversations some
boundaries
but it's all so so necessary and so
worth it that puts this hour of the
ramsay show in the books my thanks to
all the folks in the booth keeping the
show afloat and for you america for
tuning in we appreciate you guys we'll
be back with you before you know it
[Applause]
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to being well i'm george
campbell your host flying solo today the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five
five two two five it would be my honor
and privilege to take your call and help
you take the right next step for your
life and your money i host a few shows
here on the ramsey network of course
you're listening to one of them right
now the other ones are the fine print
and the entree leadership podcast you
can find all of those shows on the
ramsay network and wherever podcasts are
found eric kicks off this hour in salt
lake city eric welcome to the show
hey george how's it going great how can
i help today
hey so my wife and i got serious about
finances and life about two years ago
and we're currently on baby step six
let's go awesome um
my question for you
is what strategy um should we take
specifically with investing options
in our 529 educational plans for our
children
i love it love what you're thinking
about this stuff how old are the kids
we have a three-year-old and a
six-month-old
congratulations sounds busy thank you
yes life is great though
so you've got plenty of time for college
so i feel good about the situation
especially since you're in baby step six
so you've already opened a 529
yeah they've been open for about two
years um one of them has about fifteen
hundred dollars
the other one has about seven hundred
dollars okay
and your question about the best
strategy what do you mean by that
so we're putting in about a hundred
dollars each child per month
um but where we get confused is you know
we have the the option to invest with
the total u.s stock market
we can invest um aggressively or
balanced or moderate
um just not sure what options to choose
within the uh the platform here so are
you doing this on your own
yeah we are okay how did you end up
choosing your 529 plan
um we live in utah and we just did the
local wise this one is um provided by
the state
and so we're not working with any
company but we've considered calling you
know smartvestor pro just to see if
that's you know a good idea but
we did everything else on our own so
that's the route we're currently facing
okay cool just wanted to see where your
options were at because you know they're
state specific you can choose any state
and if i'm not mistaken utah actually
has a great 529 plan but inside of that
you're saying what's the best investing
strategy i recommend going with good
growth stock mutual funds which would
probably put you in the aggressive
category which i'm okay with because we
have plenty of time for this money to
grow
okay because what happens is you invest
in some conservative investments and
they're leaning towards bonds and that
money is not going to grow at the rate
you want it to
okay
so what is it yeah that makes sense and
that
and that stays in line with your other
advice on you know 401k investing things
like that i would invest the exact same
way inside of that 529 plan
okay so find some good gross stock
mutual fund options in there that have a
proven track record and uh there should
be plenty of options in there hopefully
if not you may want to look into other
state-specific plans but i think that
one should have plenty of options that
will help that money grow
at a at a healthier pace
okay
yeah last time we checked there were
a plethora of options so we'll take a
look there and if we do get confused
again i guess we'll call it a
smartmaster pro absolutely they can
definitely help but good for you man i
love that you guys are in baby step six
found out about this plan two years ago
and jumped into it full throttle and
you're investing for your kids future
and at three years old and six months
old they're going to go to college debt
free because of the work that you guys
have put in so really proud of you
thanks for the call
nathan joins us up next in cincinnati
nathan welcome to the ramsay show
hey how's it going great how are you
doing well
what's your question
so um
long story short um my wife and i are
debt-free
um
both of us have associate's degrees um
and
um we're currently renting we're
expecting our first daughter
next month congrats and
thank you we're so excited but
um
i guess at this point
uh we're looking into potentially
getting home but obviously the market
right now is not very buyer-friendly to
say the least um agree to agree we have
about yeah so uh right now we have about
fifteen thousand dollars saved up and
we're kind of at a place right now where
it's um i make about forty three
thousand dollars a year
uh my wife makes about 28.
um
and
once the baby comes we're hoping to have
her
we've been able to save her income
um completely away
since she started working but once the
baby
gets here we'll probably have her
go to either part time or just stay at
home completely as a stay-at-home mom so
we'd just be living off of my income
alone
um
do you feel good about that
um
we are at a place right now where we can
afford that i mean we've we try to live
pretty modestly and you know
um
but if we were to i guess getting to the
point of all of this is we're looking at
potentially getting into a home but if
we were to buy into
the housing market right now we'd
probably be looking at
at least
an eleven hundred dollar
monthly
mortgage yeah and so that's your
take-home pay with that just yours
just mine um
like i said it's about 43 000 annually
um after tithes and everything
i come back
with
roughly 2 400 a month yeah what's your
rent right now
uh
with utilities and everything we're
right at
um
9.50 or
between 950 and 100 that was a thousand
a month okay
and you're wondering should we buy right
now
yes so we have that money and so i'm not
sure if we should is your emergency
right now or
um so 15 000 would include our emergency
fund that's all the money you have is
15.
um not including our checking that's
just passed away in savings but yeah
well it sounds like that's your
emergency fund and so we're not going to
touch that we're going to start a new
fund for our down payment and so that
would be my next goal for you guys is
baby step 3b
where we start saving up for the down
payment and a lot of people tend to
pause investing in order to save this up
if it's going to take longer than three
years you probably want to start
investing at that point how old are you
two
i'm 25 my wife is 26. okay good we have
time on our side i like that so my my
job for you is to increase your income
so that you can still hit these goals so
that you're not waiting 12 years to save
up a down payment because it's going to
be tight it's going to take a little bit
of sacrifice if you can't get your
income up immediately i might go take
some side hustles maybe she's not able
to stay home full time right now so i'd
look into what those options look like
map it all out get a plan to get there
get on the same page and over time get
the income up save up the down payment
and then start investing that would be
my goal for you nathan congrats on the
daughter i'm gonna gift you guys ramsay
plus hang on the line go through that
with your wife get excited about this
child start budgeting for it that'll
give you a plan to do it ramsay plus
including financial peace university and
every dollar hang on the line austin
will pick up and get that to you this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
imagine the energy of a jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to experience
what it means
to live life to the fullest
now picture all of your favorite
speakers together on the stage
empowering you with tools and principles
that will create unstoppable momentum in
your life
well that right there that's smart
conference that's right smart conference
is back it's been three years since
we've done this event and we're so
pumped to get it back on the road in
dallas texas that's right dallas we're
headed your way
saturday october 22nd smart conference
is our biggest event of the year
and you don't want to miss it it's a
day-long opportunity to get advice from
leading experts on money personal growth
leadership mental health relationships
and your career you're going to leave
with all of the knowledge and motivation
you need to reach your goals and live
the life that you want and all of us
here at ramsay will be there all the
ramsey personalities plus some special
guests craig and amy grochelle from life
church they're coming too they're going
to speak on marriage it's going to be
fire tickets start at just 39
for a day-long event that's absolutely
incredible get your tickets now before
they sell out and this event will sell
out it's a crowd favor people travel
from all over the country to attend so
if you can make it to dallas saturday
october 22nd be there it's like drinking
from the fire hose this is a great way
to introduce some of your friends to the
ramsey way
and tickets are just 39 bucks that is
cheaper than a date night and we're
going eight to five folks we're going
full throttle all day tons of speakers
all the topics so join us visit
ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more that's
ramseysolutions.com
events
open phones this hour the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five kevin joins from my old
hometown boston massachusetts kevin
welcome to the show
what's going on george how are you doing
good i'm really hoping you have a thick
boston accent
i don't i just where i'm actually i'm
actually i live in rhode island
disappointing it's all good a big fan of
rhode island too how can i help today
right
um so i just curious you know at the end
of the month i want to be completely
debt-free for once and um
yeah so you know i'm just kind of
looking for advice i think the next step
in a sense where
you know i'm renting right now is it
smart just to keep holding off for like
the 25
down payment for a multi-family or
single family
or you know do you you invest in stocks
you know i just i'm a little it's kind
of funny from a realtor also but you
know i'm just i don't know all the
answers so just looking for a little
guidance hey that's all right that's
awesome thank you for reaching out so
you're about to pay off all of your debt
and you're wondering what is next what's
your income yeah
um
my gci last year was 123
so i you know i met it um
i needed about
90. okay
awesome well before expenses of course
now how much money do you have in the
bank and savings do you have anything
in the bank um
in the bank all together after the
payoff i'll have close to um 20 grand 20
grand so what's holding you back from
just paying off your debt how much is
there left
it's only just eight grand i guess i
could essentially just pay it off i just
wanted that one last transaction to
close down a month which i got cgc for
so i just was like all right
well i'll pull the trigger hey man if
i'm in your shoes and you want to follow
our plan that debt is gone today you got
20 grand you're gonna pay that eight
grand off that still leaves you with 12
which is a head start on baby step 3
which is your fully funded emergency
fund so what amount would that be to
have three to six months of expenses
three or six i mean i guess that would
be about 15 grand okay which means
you're probably what a month away from
having a fully funded emergency fund and
no debt
yeah absolutely by the end of june i'll
be very uh
content i guess you could say so you're
not content right now
well you know i guess i'm never content
but you know it's a difference
i want contentment for you it's okay to
have drive you can have both
but if you're following our plan that's
what you would do you pay off all the
debt you have the money to do it and
then you your next step would be baby
step three which is your fully funded
emergency fund so if you're telling me
that's 15k you'll have another 3k to go
to get to that number beyond baby step
three so let's say a month from now
you're there you've got 15k in the bank
you don't have a payment in the world
you've got a great income then we're
going to begin baby step 3b you're
telling me you want to get into you want
to buy a place for yourself
yeah and that's another thing too like
you know like i don't really see
the benefit of getting a single family
right now so you don't have any kids but
um could you get a condo or
i'm not really a fan of condo from being
honest um i don't really like the uh hoa
fees and just i don't like someone
telling what to do with my house
um well you told me you're maybe looking
at multi-family
yeah exactly
owning that but then the landlord lives
right above me which means i can knock
on his door at all hours of the night
when the hvac goes out
i know and that so that's what i was
thinking about i really want to live
with the tenants you know so that's
where i kind of like what you know i'm
confused oh my god like [ __ ] like what
do i want to do next
and i just don't know maybe i should
just hit the single family and then
start saving for the you know another
yeah investment property but like you
know i heard an episode of dave ramsey
today and today or i believe where you
should have your
kevin here's what i would do if i'm in
your shoes i'm saving up to get myself a
home i don't know what that looks like
for you
i'm i'm okay with condos and apartments
if you want to get a single family home
that's still smaller and reasonable and
you can do that with 10 20 down that
would be my next step now some people
like to invest they want to put that 15
into investments depending on your age
you may want to begin to do that while
you save up for the down payment and
then hustle to get that income up
so that's what i'm doing if in your
shoes but i wouldn't go with the
multi-family as your first property
because it sounds like a lot of headache
but i appreciate the call man thank you
so much
all right if you don't know about the
fine print let me tell you about it this
is a podcast we did back in the fall and
we did 11 episodes in the first season
and here's the heart behind the fine
print
it's all about the hidden truths that
are keeping you broke and as i looked
around and as i've been here for nine
years there are way more traps than
there are successful paths
the path to success is it's very narrow
and not a lot of people take it a lot of
people are falling for the traps out
there so we went through multiple topics
and this is a narrative style podcast if
you're a fan of you know npr's podcast
or anything like that these are about
half hour very educational they're fun
they have different experts and personal
stories and i try to weave it all
together masterfully
and so uh we did turbo tax we covered
the true cost of credit card rewards we
covered how to bulletproof your money
for the next pandemic we covered buy now
pay later with these companies like
after pay and klarna and zezel and quad
pay you name it they're out there we
covered the housing market and if now is
the worst time to buy a house we covered
bitcoin and if that's your ticket to
wealth with all the talk of
cryptocurrency
we cover the dirty truth behind your
credit score goodness gracious there's a
lot to unpack about credit scores we
also hit the student loan crisis and uh
we asked the question is it worse than
ever uh you don't want to know the
answer but you may want to listen
we also covered bankruptcy and if it's a
quick fix for struggling americans and
who bankruptcy is right for if anyone
and trying to give people some hope if
they feel like that's the next step for
them
and we also covered the holiday season
the supply chain is asked for what's
going on with the spending there and
finally we talk about robin hood and diy
investing
and so when you look at all of those you
go man there's so many things i could be
doing with my money what's the right
thing for me and unfortunately a lot of
people get suckered into the latest fad
the latest trend because their buddy
told them
they got in on crypto and they made a
lot of money
or their buddy told them you can just do
no money down real estate and you'll be
fine there's plenty of loans out there
and banks that will give you the money
without having a down payment there's
lots of people who are trying to build
their credit score because they believe
the lie that that is the price to pay if
you want to win financially and smart
people have very high credit scores
but what we found is that if you handed
me a million dollars it doesn't change
my credit score it doesn't take into
account my income
all it looks at is my relationship with
debt
and so if you want to dig in to these
traps to understand them a little deeper
to hear real stories to hear from
experts go check out the fine print
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
it's uh season one is out right now
we're working on what it looks like for
season two a lot of you have reached out
asking me when it's gonna drop i don't
have a good answer for you i apologize
but we got plenty of episodes for you to
catch up on and the other podcast that i
host is called the entree leadership
podcast where we help business leaders
men and women all around the country
small businesses get a hang of their
profits their team themselves help them
grow and all of those areas so that they
can win in this economy because that's
truly the backbone so go check out those
podcasts on the ramsay network we are
here for you this hour the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm george campbell we'll
be back with
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks welcome back to the ramsay
show i'm george campbell flying solo
today and if you're wondering why the
answer is simple they all ditched me
in orlando florida enjoying the entree
leadership summit event dave ken john
the whole gang's out there and uh so
that leaves me here but it's an honor
and a privilege so give me a call at
825-5225 and we will talk about your
life and your money christian joins us
in oklahoma city christian welcome to
the show
hey thank you guys how are you great
what's going on with you
yeah i got a question for you so i have
um my primary mortgage for my primary
residence and then i have three rental
properties two of which are paid off um
and on my rental property i guess my
question would be what would make more
financial sense to pay off my rental
property or to pay off my primary
mortgage
okay what's the numbers there
so on my rental property i owe 150 grand
it's for finance for 10 years at three
and a half percent interest and so my
thought process was
to take that rental income and double up
on those payments each month and i could
have that paid off in five years
then take
once it's paid off then take that income
that rental income from those three
properties
and double up payments and take that
take that and then my regular payment
and and apply it towards my primary
mortgage and then i could probably have
that paid off within about four years my
primary mortgage though i owe 260 000
at a 4.75 interest rate so i was just
wanted to see what would make more
financial sense yeah it's a great
question sometimes if the rental
property is a much smaller amount it's
easier just to knock that one out and
it'll free up a payment like you're
basically what you're saying which is
you want to pay off the rental use that
freed up payment to now attack your
primary right
yep what's your household income
including the rental incomes
um
about maybe 450 years between my wife
and i oh my goodness that's fantastic
so
my question is why is it gonna take you
nine years to pay off
four hundred thousand dollars in debt
well i mean we contribute to my 401k we
contribute to our money market account
our kids um college funds with two
little girls so
i mean
we have a lot going on towards that i
guess but our only deaths really are
two car payments in a boat oh boy so now
it's just got a little more complicated
we've got cars and the boat what's how
much is on the boat
oh not much maybe like 10 grand left on
that okay in the cars
um
maybe like 30 combined
we trade out our cars i mean i don't do
them i sell them and get a new one
everybody about every three or four
years just because i put so many miles
on them okay
so you've got about 40k in the boats and
the cars and then you've got 150 on the
rental outside of your primary yep
well
if you if you're following our plan i'm
just going to pay off those ankle biter
debts right there with your income just
get rid of the boat day get rid of the
car debt and start paying cash for
everything that's only going to help
your cash flow
if you want to pay these mortgages off
so that's if you want to do our plan and
then beyond that i don't mind you paying
off the rental because i think you can
do that in a year with your income
i don't see why i mean making 450 even
after taxes and 15 going towards
investing and putting some in the
college fund uh you should still have
six figures left over right yes
and so are you guys doing a monthly
budget
i mean yeah
not in your head but like on paper a
budgeting app something like that
okay
well what i'm going to do for you is
gift you guys one year of ramsay plus
and that includes every dollar premium
which is our budgeting tool it'll track
your expenses it'll connect to your bank
account because what i'm seeing here is
a guy who's done really really well
financially
but is doing a bunch of things at once
and you're not seeing the traction that
you should be seeing for a guy making
half a million dollars a year
yeah and so i think it's time to start
paying attention to every single dollar
that you have coming in and making wise
choices with where it's going and it
sounds like you're done really well
i mean you guys are going to be
multi-millionaires how old are you
43 43 and your wife
44 44. awesome
well
that's what i'm doing i'm paying off the
debts probably in the next how much
money do you guys have in just cash
reserves savings all that
savings probably close to 90 grand
awesome what would you call a three to
six month emergency fund how much
i would say probably at least 25 grand
okay 30 grand so let's just say in
theory that you parked 30 grand for your
emergency fund leaving you with 60.
the cars and the boats those payments
would be gone today right still leaving
you with another 20 grand
then we knock the rental down 20 grand
to now what 130.
then we get about the business of using
all of our incoming cash flow to knock
this thing out in the next 12 months
boom now we've freed up that payment
plus the car payments plus the boat
payments and now all we have less left
is this 260 000 mortgage which we could
then knock out within two years
yeah
so your nine-year plan just turned into
a three-year plan
doesn't that sound better
it does yeah
what's holding you back from there after
buying it just knowing that well i can
do that i just know that i'm gonna have
to buy another car eventually oh i'm not
saying to sell the car i'm saying just
pay it off
yeah yeah yeah
i understand that but when i get too
many miles in my car i have to buy
another one but how many miles are you
going
usually around 140 to 150 on my car a
year less than a hundred thousand on my
wife's no no no no no that's from the
life of the car that i have oh
oh my goodness i was like dude what are
you doing for a car
driving across the country every day
what kind of career are you and i'm just
curious critical care medical device
cells you know by provides that helps to
integrate patients but
ventilators and then all sort of wrong
patients yeah great great income with a
career like that
good for you man well hey thanks so much
for the call again you're feel free to
do what you want you're a smart guy but
i like a three or two or three year plan
versus a nine year plan and then 450 000
stays with you
aside from what you gave to uncle sam
which is a giant chunk of that because
they punish the rich they will punish
you if you make too much money there we
go our question of the day comes from
blinds.com
their 100 satisfaction guarantee means
even if you mismeasure or pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from tracy in
north carolina
she said i recently began my debt free
journey and i'm currently on baby step
two i was very excited about the
progress i was making when i got some
unfortunate news
i learned that i have thyroid cancer and
need to have surgery right away i have
excellent health insurance through my
company however i don't have the cash on
hand to pay for my out-of-pocket expense
of 4 500
should i tackle this new debt first
while only making minimum payments on
other debts or should i build it into my
debt snowball where appropriate should i
use my thousand dollar emergency fund to
cover part of the cost i'm not sure what
would make the most financial sense and
would love some guidance
wow
well tracy uh takes my breath away to
even think about getting a cancer
diagnosis like that so i'm so sorry that
you're walking through that um
praying for the best with this surgery
and that it's gone after that and you
live a long healthy life
but as far as your question the
out-of-pocket cost being 4 500 bucks
you're in baby step two no i would not
touch your thousand dollar emergency
fund on a technical level it's not an
emergency you know it's coming up and
you can't if you can't save up and pay
for it by the time it happens
which my a1 would be can you talk to the
hospital and say hey is there a cash
discount could you do this for three
thousand dollars and then you'd scrape
together the three thousand dollars as
fast as you can to negotiate a price
down at a cash discount rate now if
they're unwilling to do that yes they
would roll into your debt snowball and i
would tackle it wherever it falls in
that debt snowball and uh you know
medical debt if it's newer it's going to
be harder to negotiate it down it's not
a lingering bill that's been around for
a while but you may be able to get that
cash discount she said hey i don't have
4 500 bucks what kind of cash discount
could you guys give me if i paid today
and so i would try to scrape together
with maybe side hustles over time
whatever you can do in order to pay that
bill in full and get it out of your life
at a discounted rate otherwise let's
roll it right into that dead snowball
and hopefully you'll be out of that soon
i can't imagine having the debt on your
shoulders on top of the surgery that's a
lot to go through so give yourself some
grace it's not going to be easy
give yourself time to recover and if
that means pausing that snowball
temporarily to get your feet under you
i'm okay with that right now your health
is a priority over the lingering debts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day
proverbs 18 2 a fool takes no pleasure
in understanding but only in expressing
his opinion
goodness gracious that just described
twitter didn't it thank you proverbs for
that ancient wisdom
benjamin disraeli said the full wonders
the wise man asks
i like that
good stuff
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
campbell your host today flying solo joe
joins us up next in tucson arizona joe
welcome to the show
hey george how's it going great how are
you
i'm good i just wanted to ask you more
about baby step 3b sure
um if baby step 3b is going to be over
two years and i'm actually trying to buy
a home 100 cash do you also invest
in mutual funds at the same time as
you're saving for a home
how long is it going to take you in
order to save up and pay cash
um currently i'm in baby step two i
should be done with baby step
two on a knock in august
cool and i'm projecting that uh baby
step three will be done by
january so after that would be probably
five years
okay
my wife and i currently make a hundred
and twelve thousand
after taxes
great and what's driving you to pay cash
for the home
oh it's just motivation
and honesty is i don't i hardly hear
anybody say that they're gonna pay cash
for a home so it's just very
motivated to do so i love it i mean it's
a noble goal and we've heard some
incredible stories of people doing that
paying cash for their home
so i'm all for that but i would begin
investing how old are you two
we are 35. 35 okay
now what would the harm be let's just
put a scenario out there what if you
were able to save up 20 down and then
you were able to pay off the house very
quickly
that would be doable too could you do
that within five years
on the same timeline
yeah
i was just kind of like i know i know
you guys don't really
press a lot on
interest so i was thinking uh would
interest be a thing if i financed would
that be a thing or it wouldn't matter
really mathematically if i just paid in
cash versus
taking out a lot matter i'll give you
some numbers here so when we got our
home
we had a
3.625 interest rate on a 15-year fix
now because we paid it in 26 months
instead of paying 50 grand over the 15
years we ended up paying a little over
nine grand in interest
over 26 months
because those first payments that you're
paying it's mostly going to interest
which is not fun
so
that was a great deal for me seeing that
amortization schedule going oh my gosh i
am paying this mortgage company a whole
lot of money in interest not driving my
principal down so i'm all for listen i
hate debt as much as the next guy and i
want you to buy a home in cash i just
know with this housing market with it
being a moving target i don't want you
to get
uh discouraged because you're five years
in and now that 500 000 house is an 800
000 house and the target keeps moving
that's correct and so in a market like
this if you can save up 20 down you'll
avoid pmi which is money you're throwing
away so the lender can be protected in
case you can't pay so in that case if
you get 20 down on a 15-year fixed with
a payment that's less than a quarter of
your take-home pay i'd feel real good
about you getting in a house sooner
and then make it an aggressive goal to
pay it off really soon so hear me say
i'm all for you saving up and paying
cash and if that takes five years and
you're okay with that that's awesome
what i don't want is five years later
you call me and say you guys told me to
buy a home in cash and now the house
that i saved up for 500 000
is now worth 800 000 and i can't afford
it
that's a real possibility
and so that's why i say that um but i do
think you should begin investing if it's
going to be longer than three years
i would begin investing you can wait
three years and then begin investing but
you're 35
i want you guys to have plenty of money
in retirement so if you want to start
investing now while saving up a down
payment then once you're in those
parameters 20 down at least 15 year
fixed payment no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay then i feel good
about you getting in that house and
having the margin
to pay it off really early
okay well sounds good thank you so much
george absolutely man thanks for the
call awesome goal love to hear that call
us back when you've got that house and
it's paid for
jay joins us up next in phoenix arizona
jay welcome to the show
hey george how you doing i'm doing great
how can i help
i gotta
i think mortgage kind of questions i
love it
sitting on a bunch of uh cash in there
i'm not a bunch but i have a
a pile of cash and a savings and i'm
really hard to pull it out to address it
towards the mortgage that's the only
debt we have with our house
um i got 75k
in the how are in my in my savings
account okay
what's on the mortgage
the mortgage is about 250.
250 on the mortgage okay yup is it is it
marsha take it out and put it there or
should i i take the 75 and pull out 50
and the best bit or what
i i need help with this sure
so is this partially your emergency fund
well it was originally we started a
building we started building an
emergency fund and then we just started
saving and saving and kept you know and
got rid of all of our districts just
kept filing it into this account and i
know it's not useful in one place so
what's three to six months of expenses
for you guys
oh we're in phoenix so 15
maybe 10 even
that much so let's call it 15 000 that
we put aside
and in a different savings account i
like to keep them separate because what
happens is it gets real squishy of well
what is this money for so i would keep
your emergency fund in one account and
put all other savings goals in different
accounts
so let's just say we had 15 on the side
that leaves you with 60 correct
correct and if you put 60 on that 250
mortgage it would get it down to 190.
that sounds right
and that's what i would do
and then you're already investing 15 of
your income into your 401k or ira or
something like that
yes already okay
then that's where you would be and
that's exactly what i would do i would
put that slap that 60 onto the mortgage
bring it down to 190 and you may feel
like well george that doesn't make sense
because i could have invested this and
the payment didn't change so that was a
waste of money but if you look up the
amortization schedule you're going to
notice that you're paying a lot less in
interest now which means you're going to
see more progress on the mortgage than
you had before
so no matter what's worth it okay and
then how do i talk my wife into that
now that that's
that's a much more difficult scenario i
mean number one you can show her the
math that sometimes that helps to look
at the math and look at what the money
you're throwing away in interest to the
lender to make them rich that's enough
to upset anybody so that's one route you
can go but also having a long-term
vision for the future helps have you
guys sat down to go hey what is a
long-term goal that we want what do we
want our retirement to be like
what do we want life to be like what is
our next goal once the house is paid off
then the house payment the house
mortgage becomes a carrot you dangle to
get to the real goal which is financial
peace we want to give more we want to
retire early those kinds of things
we haven't followed the financial fees
to the core but ramsey over the last 10
years of my life has been a crucial
you know point in my my my financial
goals
and has helped me get through all my my
debt that's awesome
but it's just one of those things what's
the next step like where are we at and
we feel content i guess yeah the next
step i mean baby step six since you're
already investing is to get that house
mortgage out of your life and uh what's
the mortgage payment every month
well uh we pay a little over about 2
200. so what's the actual payment
without paying extra i think 19. okay
another thing you could do with her on
top of the interest math is going hey
what would we do with an extra 1900 1900
bucks a month
what kind of vacations would we take how
much more could we invest how much more
could we give what would that money turn
into in an investment account that kind
of stuff gets me fired up so i would
take her out on a nice date don't skimp
you guys are debt-free you know take her
to her favorite meal and have this
conversation and kind of make it a dream
date and let that be the fuel to make
this big jump which is oh my gosh we're
taking we're depleting our savings
account
we're still on a tight budget though i
tell you that's all right the one thing
the budget's been great that's the thing
that's turned us around i think man
that's awesome to hear well jay i'm
pulling for you man that's so cool to
hear call us back when that mortgage is
gone and you do a debt-free scream
either on the phone or on the stage if
you want to make the trip to nashville
we're rooting for you guys
i'm encouraged lot of awesome calls
today appreciate you all calling in and
helping me
help you take the right next step in
your money journey it's been an honor
and a privilege to solo host today
appreciate all the folks in the booth
will and kelly and austin and james and
nathan and zach the whole gang's in
there and everyone listening in tuning
in watching we appreciate you guys so
much we couldn't do this without you
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously this
has been the ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you